hey listen cloak brand don't don't don't
Brit cloak hey Brad partnering up with
minecraft dungeons good stuff good stuff
calm down let's do this
oh hello there he is wow you really do
manage to pick out your specific
character model every game yeah I feel
like you did this one for yourself so we
do like missions and stuff huh yeah you
want to do the first one seems
appropriate I don't know what happen
aways you muted weed we want to go to
cloak brand calm and get the new cloak
minecraft dungeons line up it's
especially good and especially
comfortable you can go to cloak brand
calm get it right now can we make this
go faster I think if we all accept it it
probably way jumpin Jesus Christ Wade
[Laughter]
these villagers are so what is this like
minecraft Diablo yeah minecraft Diablo
all right over here
I was really nice
cinematic whose souls are whatever um
animatic well cuz you guys suck you
don't have to be at that kind of person
if you knew me you knew I have to you
don't have to be such a gemin about it
what a Devin how dare you it's not my
fault are you the one who's being all
Deveny BAM hahaha boy that's cool that's
fine it feels good I got a bit ya chest
nice little there's going to be oh yeah
there is I got a bunch of roof roof
holes over here
rupal what's the money what's the green
thing about rubles yeah weasels rubles
yeah rubles you will never kill anything
never you know I have a bow I could if I
wanted to
we'll never so what the whole plot that
you guys missed from the cinematic is
supposed to free that man yeah we the
illah Jers are capturing the villagers
oh the illah tears are the bad ones yeah
which you know considering villagers has
villain red in it I would have thought
they would have been the mill bad guys
but they're not called the villain
udders
because that's terrible I think I think
we all know who the bad guys are all
right fairness it's on my head dude yes
straight up almost killed me and
straight up did kill wait I guess merely
I'm gonna hang out let me just kill
these skellies and I'm totally rescue
buddy no worries naught is spawn Oh God
oh goodness gracious not at night how
you doing wait all feeling great I'm
happy
hey wait no you know what I'm theme
we're revisiting drop Minecraft motifs
mark blue wait up with dynamite I did it
could not be more apropos Bob you set
off the dynamite the whole like butters
voice no no that was like no mark set
off my dynamite I was just laying the
dynamite yeah yeah so did these guys not
explode if you snipe them I'm pretty
sure the death is very violent freaking
psychopath he didn't see that there are
creepers I thought there are zombies
wait used to revive me and not mark
thanks friend thanks you're gonna like
inside each other kinda hard to select
you know how it is this precision aiming
game a little tough to choose one one
idiot died right on top of another idiot
[Laughter]
oh geez okay away forever
you think we have like a lifetime supply
of arrows oh no we don't we have 56
arrows how many arrows do for you boys I
don't often like 80 I'm down to 66 I've
got 70 I hope we get some more you know
the charge them right you guys in a
church the church no hold it down and
before you fire does more damage I've
really been wasting my arrows kill these
cows
yeah we're sheep that one had shadow
brew invisible Wow
well I leave a pretty conspicuous trail
of smoke and sparks and things but oh no
I don't know what that means
yeah the cows make zombies are working
together the cows are clearly other side
of the really real I'm sorry I killed a
cow and I dropped pork reserve
Billington's yeah you know I'm not gonna
lie I didn't know what to expect coming
in is is actually pretty fun I like the
mechanics are very pleasant it is nice
feel I don't feel like I don't
understand what's happening and every
time I've died it's clearly been my own
fault who every time Wade has died it is
clearly his fault every time we decide
it's clearly been his own fault yeah
probably was an Abreu
okay so items are shared between us I'm
guessing okay dead cow yeah I think I
shot that 100 ytyt boys what is going
inside oh no nothing in here guys
another nadir oh cool thanks much nothin
in here nothing in hey look it's Legend
of Zelda rolls where's that GroupWise a
rupee over there hmm what could possibly
be in this hey you knew you guys come
running oh wait oh you get your own Oh
Oh what the hell
okay I get my own clicked on the chest
that you guys grabbed everything I got
my own so each of us can open our own
chest so the rules we must declare these
rules now you open you get you know one
steal anyone else's open Z's okay he
said it again I was turning you out no
one steals anyone else's open Z's
no one's open Z Zeus you keep your own
open Z's Oh
Open Sesame Open Guetta me man we're
really raining down hell on these dweebs
winters later a-holes yeah this is what
you get for making a nest for your
family what is that a treasure Pig it's
a treasure Pig it's a loose snork er I
picked up an ax apparently I got wolf
armor okay so from that I got my own
stuff snacks oh I got wolf armor dude do
you see my wolf armor that's cool
is it still dripping with the juices
inside or is it really no it's pure wolf
inside and out oh that's pretty cool hey
guys if you hit tab you can open it very
hard to use many different mini-map and
tab you mean went down on the
directional pad no I mean tab because
I'm not an idiot
Oh worry I took care of it in a non
stupid way oh you're down I think that
guy just killed you straight up Thanks
you are free mr. villain here oh that
that's probably the man's who killed me
he was big man's so when's this gonna
get to like Diablo 3 levels of
ridiculous speedrunning killing millions
of things at a time because that's what
I'm looking for yeah that would be
exciting okay what'll be Diablo 2 mods a
little bit mobs would be like immune to
things like no swords Club only
club all night no taxis open Z's a good
idea mom I think she do no piece yet
neither earth way was my idea
good call wait yeah good combo that's
cheap apparently ahh
not you oh wait there's a creeper I
remember right sorry something about
those hang on oh god I'm stuck help sort
of trouble it's conjunction they
conjunction eyes conjunction its
conjunction junction word are you on
about
I'm watching conjunction junction then
what's the deal with conjunctions I'm
trying to learn how to roll properly oh
yeah we have a roll okay chess you guys
right there yes why I got some rupal sin
it Bruce
what is that skeleton silly the video is
that worthy of here no oh there's so
many
yep that's the thing about here this
place that's the thing about what's
happening right at this moment I can
tell you oh that's so bad it's fine just
shoot it with your charm arrows and
whatnots yep
and I like the fireworks but it needs a
he's a slower faster cooldown needs a
slower cooldown I agree you wouldn't
agree to that if you were smart but
you're obviously dumb it was a test you
fails man for being dumb I've got
hunters armor that's Garbo and I have it
I have no armor I got a bow even though
I had a bow I got a bow got a better bow
oh it is better okay well this is like
the witch from left 4 dead moaning do
I hear alimony I don't hear a thing wait
wait don't you know it was good I was
accidentally time to you through a
megaphone so drop this Bob this is the
thing I can do
oh I do can't drop it there's only a
salvage option Salvage you can salvage
apparently and get my buns to craft
I guess so what are you guys have so
many arrows I can see how many errors
have you holding Horton arrows a little
bit where'd you get all those errors it
stolen from you oh it's just affairs for
first for ya
there again knows how I miss misbuttoned
no you're way ahead of us when you're
aware up and around
oh sorry am I going wrong with you no
it's just the way knows this is the way
this is the way I said it normal like oh
yeah I play dangerously whoa oh no the
arrows not pointing this way we lost the
arrow but Bob do you see there's that
only for me oh come on game wolf armor
god damn it farmer farmer all right spin
it myself
give me that Gus off to salvage it I
guess I don't go to a it's not very nice
I only on level one oz
okay I don't know I stuff like that
sometimes I can teleport to my friends
intended to be spooky I'm teleporting
what does my arm doing I'm here what if
I teleport didn't do what are you guys
up to get over here so I suck in my soul
don't suck my chess I'd suck your soul I
know you would and I appreciate that
more warmer you gotta be shoving it in
me no it wasn't wolf Armour I'm sorry I
it was something else oh cool I don't
have that either
you need my I have another bow ah that's
nice man it's real good
I was supposed to go a little bit
further than that we all listen is it
for sheep summoning summoner or
something I switch classes yes no stuff
from that did we rescue anybody I don't
remember actually we were unlocking
their boxes and they were just
disappearing hmm we did some right guys
dude like every loot possible that round
yeah me too
Oh crazy look at me look at what I have
done
look at my greatness look how many items
I used how much damage I took all from
mark how did you use any item it says
the least damage taken yeah freaking
liar liar yeah you're Walmart this 6500
damage and only 300 of it was to you
guys I got a tasty bow okay just I don't
like that I got a bow please give me
some wolf armor I got boots of swiftness
you don't have that do you
shut up on the best look at my dog a
blacksmith where our blacksmith random
gear appropriate for my level hunters
but how will I be one with the wolf Eve
occasion robe oh it gives me 25%
artifact cooldown hell yeah that sounds
pretty good let's look at how cool I
look now look at me nerds that's pretty
cool Oh have a suite for me okay I have
anything squishy
that's my new crossbow no one has that
I'm a wizard yeah well I got a dog so
you can shut up we've got options we've
got redstone mines kakdi Canyon soggy
swamp pumpkins I wait a minute I'm sorry
kakdi Canyon kakdi Canyon I don't think
that's right Pam can coasters Sagi swam
just pick one bro I want to go through
my crossbow at people buy crossbow if
you guys go to cosmetics do you have the
hero cape and the baby chicken too oh
yeah I totally have those things look
now I have a pet baby chicken I don't
know what you guys are talking about all
I've got is my sweet cloak available at
cloak brand.com among other cool items
you can get cloak brand okay okay he
wanted to play with us today because
cloak brand look at our chicken friends
hey guys there's some stuff over here I
got a cutscene I have a cutscene why do
we don't get the cut why don't you would
get the cutscenes yeah you suck maybe
you've got a bootleg version of the game
you what that's rude
it's all your fault that's a little rude
oh wait if you hit em it tells you where
there's one secret and two chests in
this area mm yeah game had ordering a
good [ __ ]
Hey look guys I did a thing I did it
guys huh sheer beautiful what faster I
hope you go first
you're jealous of my dog I'm a chicken
I'm Chicken Hawk yeah but mine is
actually a tax no no it'll heal it'll
heal
oh my god that's baby zombies I don't
like that I don't think these are
zombies yeah I mean hang on yay oh my
god I shoot three fireworks with my
didn't find that I'll be good
wait what did I just get I got a new bow
a trick bow I got a trick bow sounds
pretty cool there's a trick whoa dude
wait no do that again oh I love it I
love it oh hey how do you get rid of the
TMT oh I didn't do anything I walked
over here talking about you that's
looking good that's what you very much
like you're not reviving him no no no
the night will hurt you what does that
mean oh that seems bad ah
oh no it's funny women die I don't think
I disagree only hordes of enemies Batman
Christmas Jesus Christ who's gonna be be
ah blows now yeah blow o'clock my dude
and receive you are stuck in a corner
well jeez there's so badiy yeah
that really escalated coming to gay I
guess
oh no I meant twice but alright thank
you Bob
oh gee you guys remember when you're
able to heal holy frickin hell I'm down
again Wow ah
these guys I treasure that's another
trick mo Oh whose what range dude is so
doodly what I just yeah I got I got a
trick baby yeah I think your bow might
be better still I'm out of arrows holy
crap that's a shame to hear you hate to
hear it I don't seem like the kind of
thing that not good this guy's gonna
really boink me can anyone give me an
assistance nope coming over he's good
all right he's waiting to blank me I saw
here I didn't see his name wait don't go
this way why over where all the bad Bros
was dang
there's nothing over see aren't you glad
I pointed that out in major yeah yeah
man we got experience yeah jinx ha ha
I'm up here now supplies for me I don't
have any arrows but if some right here
how do you how do you emote or left
trigger if you have a rapier older W is
supplies mark said
which what watch me open the chest and
then take all my [ __ ] down your arrows
can I give you arrows I have 237 must
have given you some know you're
salvaging that salvage some arrows this
is why we get mad at you just to be
clear I rank bow I guess the arrows went
with the low rank bow no I just solved
my bows they didn't go I think you just
somehow stupid you're way out of some
arrows it was just like well I'm useless
now my only good thing is my crossbow I
need new friends you've been saying that
did I take all of your arrows friend who
had several hundred arrows we got a lot
incoming a lot in alive come Allah Allah
use use your kiting abilities oh there's
a creeper over here hey someone dropped
arrows for me I'm fast
alright I'm doing the I did I did a
beacon three out of five I thought I was
gonna die I really sincerely thought
this guy looks big no bigger they are
the closer they are to my height and Bob
sight and now my right mark short
oh hey guys I wasn't actually going
there when I talked but the number is a
sliding Bob and I was like well I guess
now i slided mark and you know just
there's no really murdering the cat
actually they dropped me I spawned way
back way back okay okay I like the
scream in the distance that you got for
that thing full of rubies I saw uh
where's the secret secret where's the
secret there's a secret if you press
them there's a secret we have a guy
there's no M button on my controller
okay well on the bottom of your thing
next to your health it has a little I
got stuck down the stairs okay I'm
leaving now boochi boochi DC little map
icon to the bottom you see and I pushed
it but I don't see no secrets on it
bottom left it literally says secret
zero one no I'm not seeing it I got
nothing I dislike your tell you I'm
looking at my screen there is nowhere on
here that says secrets
oh is it right there in front you have
to double press to get the turn map open
not the little map mmm well Wade didn't
tell me about the little map and the big
man I thought Matt I thought I pressed
him and I've got one man no if you don't
get hit one of those oh he did oh my god
that was easy sure I mean honestly we
were never actually in very much peril I
don't think I got hit once and it would
be bad
look all of my health Oh TNT go away
Oh spelunker armor what's that - I got
that - but it's kind of Garbo compared
to our good armor oh I have a shadow in
the night my dog
oh this crossbow is the best no charge
up oh that's that's perfect I love that
I didn't know that was gonna happen
gonna happen it's okay to hurt mark
that's and I didn't steal his only
source of invaluable attack that's
interesting it's not interesting not
really not and it was pretty interesting
I'm very interested not really and now
interesting it is it's not it was a fad
alright just whatever the hell that is
alright I'm gonna stand right here and
not take anything I don't want them
leave them there to die
what why I don't need this Eris it's
like a pack of cigarettes and you're
trying to quit I need I don't need I
don't need I don't want I never wanted
the way I mean this is secret we need to
get a key seems like
seems like if we just wail on it enough
ya know it'll definitely open it
something I'll probably yeah yeah sure
yeah dude the heavy cross knows where
it's at no charge up jeez I believe
that's what I have right now yeah
instant hits no charge up that's it's
the it's it's the stuff I guess we gotta
find a key there's some kind of temple
looking thing with a lot of coffee cups
ambush these coffee cups of people just
left lying around my back is that good
yeah open the blue key door but it said
find the gold key yeah we'll get it oh
we gotta go up so challenge much respect
when hang on
I've got a oh hang on why is that thing
so big did you put the kid I don't know
where'd the Kiko I don't see the key did
you drop the today did it fall off me
why did you drop the key me oh my god oh
hey look the key son how did I drop the
key oh my god it wandered away just
wanna live well that was easy secret
chunk chunk oh hey where's the secret
you've been talking up so much I don't
know it doesn't tell me where's the
secret it just says there isn't one come
out where you can't apparently move the
map when you're looking at which is kind
of stinky balls look guys
the gold heat fine what guys I found the
gold key but it's been quite a spell
since I've heard you exclaim in that
manner before since you've heard me
squawk out loud yeah what
you dropped your key oh you frickin heck
yeah there was this is a creeper there I
don't know if you saw that I might have
all right getting this old yeah I liked
all the skeletons in the backer just
like going on out that door I can look
out well where are my friends old by Oh
weird which I had eyes boots stupid
skeletons not having guys jeez guys come
on holy monkey skeletons
I mean we all have a relative that's a
skeleton at some point I've not been
enchanting any of my stuff oh my god
doing just creeper say I always think
they have less health um I'll mail it a
few times and they never never die
before I die oh this is secret secret I
don't know I need to get better dodging
dodging is really what I need this guy
weird but it's Amaris
everyone stand here and this feels
important this feels important it does
nice Brown mr. huben sacrifice of course
is the secret like something we got a
hit in the environment or is it just
gonna be obvious so if you press him
down where we just came from there like
a little hat shaped thing at the bottom
that there's like a little tiny walk
path no no no that can't possibly be it
there's nothing over here wait I have an
idea
a big-ass waste of time yeah probably
not did something should we just go
onward yeah let's just go on probably
not it it's probably not it Oh what was
that I tried to do my you're going off
the level drop love ledge there look
down here look in quick I'm here I'm
teleporting yeah look down look there's
like an archway down there what if you
have to stand on top of this and perform
a dance come to that cactus Oh what the
hell I'm on the cactus oh no I just
jumped on it I rolled on it yeah so
there is a way you can manipulate the
environment by rolling onto things
interesting so that means you can
probably make the jump from hang on
there's only one gap difference down
here then one gets this jump should be
possible would jump what jump you
talking about yes whoa wait full of
secrets I'm gonna teleport to oh look at
me I'm a genius
what is this once we found the secrets
[Music]
we're here secret what look at this cool
place we're in and probably trapped now
oh now do we get off of here Oh guys
there was a desert walk path oh wow a
path you can just walk down yeah but why
would they have you be here why would
they give you you did it oh I made such
a cool jump I don't know
I'm teleporting yo yo yo yo why is it
every time I accomplished something cool
it's ultimately nothing it was pretty
cool though
you should feel bad but I do you should
yeah obviously you should clear I feel
like ass garbage
oh come on of Eris you shouldn't be that
that's your own dog calm down creepers I
[Laughter]
don't feel so good just start good God
this is I'm Salvage entero [ __ ]
alright huh you guys seemingly have
health bars
you just gotta use the health potion
there bub
I couldn't already used it once my image
there bud once and never again is this a
secret I think I'm fine I already went
over here and there's nothing the secret
of getting stuck on stairs
it sounds so successful when you fall
fall down you come back it's all haha I
mean if you were the one to defeat death
I think it would be pretty celebratory
[Music]
secret I'm very disappointed yet it to
us
yeah that's pretty bad although we
didn't explore in the beginning very
much so it might have been our fault
no pinion we could have gone back to the
beginning guys wait no I don't want to
do that guys look at all the blocks I
walked on man mark you are so good you
really say that mobs defeated 85% for me
no no it's all corrupted to be thinking
I got wheat poochy poochy lava love love
what we do
guys look that's incredibly useful and
horrifyingly distracting right now I
knew that and I knew that was on the
ground it was like alright what's next
we've got we just unlocked the desert
temple maybe we should go there perhaps
we should all right recommended power is
10 we're 5 we're gonna die I think we're
fine there's three of us so where power
is actually 15 because of math cinematic
ah yes the beautiful cinematic we
definitely all get to see wow that's so
cool we've got three secrets on this
level inside
let's find none of them again I like
that strategy apparently the secret of
the last level was by the blue key
location after all that's where we was
Oh anyway that was a great cinematic oh
yeah I forgot you get to see things it
was cool there's a lot about the secrets
yeah actually but I'm not gonna tell you
because it's a secret well this is a
secret if I've ever seen one sin though
it's in the water get in there mark
that's the water it's in the water so
the water is an arrow now it didn't hurt
you shut up now
good shut up oh we go
working tom tells me maybe this is gonna
be tough oh god no not into him don't
worry don't worry more worry mark worry
I'm worrying that's all I'm doing
oh my god mark definitely time to worry
wait where are you oh my god jiminy
Christmas
Wow I think maybe this we should maybe
good go to the swamp oh I feel like our
power levels to be like three times
higher oh good maybe we need to get good
maybe the only thing is we're bad maybe
that's the maybe that's the deal don't
tell people to suck your bean wait
that's gross and rude
whoa this big guy he's problems okay why
didn't I get his soul his soul seems
like you'd be powerful why are you
getting people's soul how are you doing
that I have a thingy that sucked souls
and then I released a beam of soul to
some people oh that is silly why do you
vote you both have these beams I don't
have these beams yeah you broke the cube
you got the cube got some wheat I didn't
get a cube I got we good cube can I
change the angle I'm looking at my
scopes that looks like there's a button
on this wall no it's isometric bro
isometric baby oh that chain no there
was a ghost on my screen it's a chain in
my face scary chain
[Music]
can't touch me can't touch me if I'm
beating your ass I really wish I had
this soul cube and not the stupid llama
doesn't do it the whole cube is dope you
should get a salt cube cube I would love
a soul cube sokeep sounds fun I got fire
tasty bone I got that you want tasty
bone hey so you don't worry I sold them
thank you Oh I'm in the middle of it I'm
going to die huh protect me I have one
health I'm so low like touch anything
please don't let them touch me soul cube
soul cubes great man I want to give us
what's up I would love it but I got I
have my armors like bonus in melee
damage oh whoa Jesus what the hell
torment quiver
it's unique oh hell yeah baby oh oh
venom blaze oh yes I did you get mark
I've got a you got a wait no I just got
a glyph you got a venom glitter I got a
level 12 unique venom glue I was so
happy about my glue I got it good guys I
got a level 12 unique with her armor wow
look at me well I
you look pretty awesome I look pretty
with arresting him I get more regular
glyph I got I was just a mark that's a
cool orchid going to tell you what seems
like the kind of person that wouldn't
have a cube yeah yeah you really don't
have a cube do you but I'm if you could
be also hewiii kind of like got gear for
the melee oh and I should get better
glue this awesome Glade markets greens
soulkey you know we got a big dungeon we
got to get through it's gonna be tough
let's get to it
wait I think I got my clave
can you stop walking next to me that'd
be really cool oh yeah I can walk ahead
if you want to protect you no no no I'm
just like staying away from me would be
the ideal scenario yeah watch out for my
dog in me oh I also got a torment quiver
that's Ray around Wow look at that
damage ah that was really cool mints
that's cool clouds I leave does it like
poison that's that's pretty cool wow I
just like mow through them with his
magical glaive
yeah that's nuts you see the milk no no
we got actually we're all good all of us
are good we all good at the same time
we're all good you good you equally good
as the really good yeah equally good I'm
stuck help no I don't need help
look I'm basically invincible with this
new armor I have oh it's wonderful
oh I'm so
I've got it wow you still feel pretty
good about your dog along Mocambo we get
next the gold key I'll lead the way
it's not that impressive actually you
know I know there's a secret here and
I'm going to find it okay you get it
buddy it looks like there's a secret
there where is you see the big shaft I
see it go for it man I really wish I had
a better glaive you know uh yeah like
mine you know what that's like mark yeah
like my glaive pretty you're super
handsome brave yeah where is it with my
wedding is it I bet we're about to find
a secret right over Wade's head I
actually think he might be right okay so
what if we oh yeah oh this is totally oh
nice nice nice nice get that no that's
totally it though
okay thank you mouse mouse mouse mouse
house like cliff going you don't have a
global hole yeah okay wait if I oh no
that's not it what a classic types is it
a button are they always buttons I don't
know I feel like this is pretty clearly
like leading us towards that you know
yeah looks like but there's no like
freaking out
dang it yeah it's uh it's a hypes and a
half can you do another dive like on an
angle up to the left for hide it didn't
let me go there
tis unfortunate but clearly this this
elevated platform area with a shining
bright light on it is just for
decorations
apparently mmm whatever it's fine it's
fine it's not here don't exist guys it's
not real
[Laughter]
oh well no big loss no it's no soul cube
that's for sure
am I right guys so could you buy wait
why don't we explore this area to the
left over here that's a good question
what is there
I mean ruin or holy soul Q baby there uh
problem hey you guys seem to be gone yep
for my wedding the whole side area yeah
we're why are you still looking for
secrets man I'm not good get over come
on die just die okay hi oh wait I spy a
chest who interesting yes II definitely
can't go that way
oh I found a switch II do mm-hmm does
that do anything not over this way
but there's another chest here by me
okay so there's this got to be switches
that lead to the chest so what it is I
don't know they're switched over here
and a chest with a soul knife so my
sword a level seven soul knife why not
man the damage thrust attack wants to
soul gathering sounds for your soul look
at my soul
[Music]
that's so before you do that yeah I did
for you man I can't make those notes for
me so so did we get is there four
switches so I get the little soul knife
so let's it's a downgrade yeah mine is
too but uh I just got a rare short bow
interesting do I need this all cube to
use this all knife is it do I you can
gather souls they're just useless for
you start gathering some Souls you
should need to practice yeah mark you
should get some souls then we'll have a
bunch ready for your soul cube wait how
do we get up here is there another chest
that we have an opener is the there's
the big dope chest over here I guess
that's probably the payoff this mark got
its all night I opened it okay okay
and seen that yet did we go down this
away oh yeah
stuff open over here yeah I guess that's
it you know someday I'll get some pretty
cool stuff you know so you go dude you
guess the whole knife yeah I got a soul
knife for level 1 common soul knife dude
that's my level 7 that's all knife I
feel like there's my Lama is very
painful death you know teleporter
accidents when you teleport into a wall
that's what happened to my llama I got a
theory
never mind there's a little part down oh
don't worry
Oh for those of us with the soul thing
you don't get the loot pick oh you right
I got way more armor I got I got a bow
Sherpa loved ones in common I got a
green level 14 bow Marty
I'll salvages I got money is what I got
I got money guys yeah you'll definitely
get some more good weed out of that
chest when we get back to base don't
worry get some good weed fine
blurring guys I think I found a boss yes
things went great but I'm also fighting
different people I'm coming Bob okay I
can just stand at range and shoot him
with my arrows guys here's a chess cool
that sounds cool Souls gathered I can
get more souls for my thing I don't
there's an Enderman over here and I need
some help if you could please he's
really giving it to me yeah we'll be
there in a second
help me hey I'll teleport to help me go
there you go come back here you weenie
oh I heard him down by Marky easy rare
soul knife level 9
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'll get some good gear 12 sold knife oh
all right if we use the environment to
our adventure survived the ambush Oh
Milo please do not die that sounds great
well this poison glaive I really don't
like Michael it's so slow I just said
why what's wrong with it it's slow and
it doesn't do anything special like
poison I recommend getting a poison one
yeah the poison one seems cool all right
that was good good choice good spread
out all right got it go these chests
aren't I think the hardest part of this
game so far I do wonder someone there is
like lifesteal aura on this thing I'll
try it let's see maybe it'll get me a
better gear if I have better gear on you
know what I mean higher level yeah was
there like a big chest that had a soul
cube cuz a lot of these items seem to be
about souls and I don't have well I got
it just from beating the last level
between the levels there
that yeah you got we a look a clave yeah
I got wheat I have a cool place I don't
like you guys I don't think you do
yeah I do but it's not as good as yours
mark I would imagine not salvage it
already because you're the glaive daddy
I am the glaive daddy there's so there
is nothing here again yeah some of those
back alleys don't have anything I'm fine
hey we're level ten words enough we're
high enough level to get through this
level sick good job yes if you look in
the inventory it says your power next to
you I'm power ten right now so level ten
what I'm power what's your power mark
wait what is your power ten mark what's
power but come on I see a 10 next
tomorrow oh come on buddy what's your
power don't make me don't make me
inspect you and find out for myself
it can be for it can be for three right
now with my my 35% damage reduction I
remember I could put on this thing with
a life steal or and you know sorry about
that that's not what I meant that's not
how I meant for that to go down man loot
big oh we're stuck how do you guys have
such high I got the farmer totem of
shielding that sounds cool
rare level ten thief armor you meet you
I just realized my enchantment on my
armor was cowardice that worked out for
you yeah it's you know I'm gonna replace
my my dog with a totem of multi shot
tree
[Music]
that did alright alright guys I'm up to
your level now I've my power is five
that's good
we're all on equal footing right sure
yeah
five yep don't think he's really
carrying his weight mom what what was
that oh don't make fun of the man's
weight that's not very nice this egg I
just found in the gave me some mistake
loot Pig yeah we're about to have a
sweet Bush yeah there's something going
on over here
Oh what have you done Bob what have you
do I do that yeah you did that yeah you
did though get in my shield
Oh oh cool actually thank you hi died
instantly
well don't die instantly Bob al Qaeda mo
worried he's only on me are you gonna
stop being dead all right that guy looks
at mean I just died well don't die then
they're dead weight you calm down now
that doesn't sound good
for something big ooh holy [ __ ] that
hurts this guy's tough oh that's a lot
of damage oh hey bud yeah that green
ball that he shoots is a potent yeah
lunch daughter no not for me
yank this hole to you maybe if you
weren't so wimpy Dimpy it wouldn't be a
one chatter oh my god
the circle of friends is back I don't
like that oh my good god oh my god Oh
like this don't die
see all that power lovely do nothing for
you the circle of wizards Bob's on you
maybe oh good
what did you why did you die in a corner
the why did you do this I thought I was
gonna come gonna stay free live in the
corner it's some stupid son of a woops
things died the corner right god damn
a-holes why all right all right good we
get a fresh start
that's what we wanted anyway hey at
least he's not he doesn't he'll back up
that's nice I thought we'd start from
scratch would forget all about what
happened so cute
burning him down baby yeah he's almost
done whoo we're so good I'm so good
getting your [ __ ] at me you really wants
whoa whoa I think we're about to have
circle of friends not quite oh yes
little friends there it is there's so
many green beans stopped three beans Hey
look
learn to dodge learn to I thought he was
aiming for Bob and then he switched yeah
you really you really he really got you
Oh God okay he's almost there just
Newcombe Newcombe so Cuba don't have
these souls you got to get some souls
wait so people don't get hit by those
hey thank you I got real armor oh yeah I
got the wither armor I already have
accepted you even better the exact same
armor I already had that was not as good
as the armor no I think my low-level
armor is better cuz it does more damage
and more damage reduction oh I don't
know salvage the grand Marlar but it's
oh man I just salvaged everything I just
myself--it everything I'm back to power
level 3 by the way sick dude I'm up to
11 I'm gonna pretend like I'm powerful
I'm just gonna pretend it's just a fun
game where we just kill it we have fun
that's all it is yeah it's just a casual
casual fun time you know yeah yeah I'll
mark you'll get it later when it matters
more yeah yeah yeah where we going these
look like places to go oh here you go
mark oh this way we're here
well that's unfortunate oh there is Wow
I think this I think this low-level
armour that I have is actually better I
take way less damage so for all of my
low-power a quite good look out guys
here come Wow
spiderweb oh you really got stung in
there sure did
that's a fortune I got stuck after ISO
cube
don't worry also cube him out of here
all right thanks buddy
without you I'd just be a babe in the
woods lost the end we call the chest and
zero secret secret yeah you what hey
look guys I bought I dropped random food
items when I heal now that's great
that's great
look how fast I am so good all right
cool let's get now yeah I'm ready for
some sweet sweet loot loot baby unable
to connect Oh what no loot
yeah it's that first serious though
[Music]
click online game again huh I'm trapped
in a loading screen so I got nothing oh
I got boots of swiftness again I'm gonna
join you I guess
I'm gonna get my loot right I'm super
duper stuck in Minecraft I can't join
you wait online servers may have just
gone down I click to create online game
I'll create my own I'm still I'm still
unloading look in my loo
I got my loot ah that's the same total
machining again oh my god with the unn
[Music]